[Music]
told him how proud of him I was and
thanked him for all the work he and his
coasties are doing to save lives I'm
grateful for the brave women and men
federal state local folks working so
hard they're all working as one team
hear that from the governor as well as
from the federal folks
President Biden personally calling First
Responders including members of the
Coast Guard who risked their lives to
rescue others from the devastation of
hurricane Ian ironically one of those
Heroes technician second class Zach lash
says he will lose his job by the end of
the year thanks to the president's own
vaccine mandate Florida Congressman
Michael Waltz is a former Green Beret
commander and member of the House armed
services committee and he joins us now
Congressman if you can believe it the
man that the president called to thank
for his heroic actions is going to be
fired at the end of the year because of
the president's own policies what do you
make of this
yeah he's one of uh 2600 Nash uh excuse
me coasties that uh that are in this
position and I can tell you what the
disabled woman in a wheelchair that he
strapped to himself uh an extracted uh
it saved her life she didn't care that
he hadn't received a vaccine we have
over a thousand National Guards men and
women in the Florida National Guard that
are also in the same position on the
verge of getting kicked out of the Guard
uh with with no pay-in benefits losing
their retirement they're out there on
the front lines right now and and the
people that they're giving water food uh
protecting from looting and crime they
don't care uh the Floridians that are
out there they're saving they don't care
but yet the Pentagon is sticking to this
stubborn asinine policy that is not
following the data and the science look
yeah the CDC has changed the guidelines
it is clear the vaccine doesn't stop the
spread you know one one could argue it
made sense when we thought that it did
but it no longer does this is an
extremely healthy population so the
argument that it's going to affect
Readiness just doesn't hold water look
and at the end of the day on top of it
all guys we have a major recruiting
crisis we are falling short particularly
in the Army by thousands and thousands
of men and women that they can't bring
in to replace these people they're on
the verge of kicking out they have got
to stop this mandate it doesn't make any
sense and it's hurting people
the point that you made is the exact
same one that Mr lash made quote if I
had asked any of the people I saved
yesterday if they wanted to come with me
even though I am unvaccinated every
single one of them would have said yes
he thanked me yet the vaccine mandate is
what's kicking me out I just love my job
and I'm really good at it I feel like
this is the job that I was born to do do
you think any of this public pressure
will force any of these Washington
bureaucrats to say you know we need to
change this up now or if this point is
this all about saving face
yeah there's just this stubborn ideology
uh that that just doesn't make any sense
look I get it you know I'm I'm a colonel
uh in in the military and as a Green
Beret in a national Guardsman I get it
you you give a platoon in order to take
the hill they have to follow that order
for good military and discipline but as
a leader and this is what I'm asking of
the Pentagon leadership you also have to
reevaluate your orders you have to
change your orders when the situation
changes and you know if you have someone
getting into a submarine or getting into
a tank that you thought were going to
infect others that's one thing but since
the vaccine now doesn't stop the spread
it's a personal health decision the CDC
agrees let's reevaluate this order but I
can tell you what uh if we flip the
house I hope to be the chairman of the
military Readiness committee and if the
Pentagon won't change we're going to
legislate it and force them to change we
have to take care of these people who
have been out on the front lines all
during the pandemic many of whom by the
way have not natural immunity because
they already got the virus and the
pentagon's not taking that into account
either it just makes no sense to hurt
these folks and we're talking big
numbers guys you know 15
000 just in the Army alone on top of the
15 000 that they fell short that's from
a recruiting standpoint that's three
divisions worth of soldiers and oh by
the way we have the Russians threatening
nuclear war and we have a massive major
Chinese build up Common Sense has got to
rain here yeah there's also this latest
yougov CBS News poll it shows that 68
percent of people believe that rights
and freedoms are at stake in the midterm
elections and a lot of people view that
as how people see the overturning of Roe
versus Wade but that could also mean how
people view pandemic policies and
lockdowns and everything that happened
in 2020. 15 seconds to you unfortunately
but do you still think that those things
are on top of mind for the American
people
well I think first and foremost the
economies uh the economy crime border
inflation or top of mind uh for for this
midterm but this Freedom issue you're
you're right it goes both ways and at
the end of the day when it comes to the
military the commander-in-chief himself
Joe Biden said the pandemic's over so
let's adjust Congressman Michael Waltz
thank you for joining us as always we
appreciate it I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis